so everybody knows disney bought the
star wars the rights to Star Wars the
entire expanded universal whole thing
from George Lucas and starting in 2015
they're going to be making a film every
summer and it's going to be the trilogy
789 every other year with little one
character spin-offs after that and I'm
very excited about this but I have to
say part of me is a little sort of taken
back by that just everything this feels
so corporate what once was something so
special to me and he fought the system
and you know created something so
brilliant in this whole world and now
it's just Disney giant machine is this
just the way everything just ends up
being I've three things to say one my
husband started his writing film career
because he saw Star Wars and he was so
inspired secondly I don't know the
difference between Star Trek and Star
Wars did his President Obama no I mean I
really do but I feel I don't I could and
the third is I once when I was a little
girl I watched a movie called the long
weekend the Lost Weekend and in the
middle of the movie they came on and
they said we put the second reel on
first by accident and like I watched
this whole I mean it was unheard of yeah
right and they played the whole thing
again like they started from the
beginning that's how I feel what star
it's like I don't know did it start the
first time like it's very confused is
amazing that aside five-person it can be
very confusing what do you think well is
this just sad that everything just goes
so corporate and even that they've laid
it out this way like for the next six
years every summer and we're going to
make you off enough enough yeah and at
the same time Disney laid off like 150
people i worked at lucasarts that was
creating all the video games for Star
Wars okay first I have never seen a
single star wars movie nuff nothing so
if you want me to stop I will we may
have to not show now but he's not the
Booker I will have to talk to I agree
with you though because I knew that
there were what three to begin with and
then they were like this is the prequel
and I was like oh cuz this happened who
what and that's why I'm not really
interested in it very much I think also
because I hadn't seen when I was young
so I just didn't care okay you're a big
it's I I mean every almost everything i
believe is built on something from the
Star Wars universe so you know let's
take this a little back from Star Wars
so and focus on the idea that can we do
anything original any more like that's
an area go ahead it's like it in a way
to me it seems like something that is a
cult classic something that you enjoy
and you're clearly not alone it becomes
more like the scary movie franchise
where it just gets more ridiculous when
it's like scary movie 13 and you're like
oh it's just part of the spin-off are
they gonna bring that character back to
because it's it's just almost like a
joke after a while yeah but the
corporate end of it that's the part that
scares me that we just keep instead of
coming up with original thought good cry
you know there's some kid that's 15
right now writing some amazingly
brilliant thing right that'll probably
never get produced because the you know
the corporations will just you know gone
can we spin off Marvel and big
blockbuster right now when you go to I
mean you go to the movies or I ok so you
don't rent it I dressed up for revenge
either descent I've never sold that
ought to go yeah I've never said that a
sniff that was no sixth and lord Lorrie
bluidy but it's Friday on Tuesday yeah
so is it just naive of me am I just a
while thinker to believe that maybe
corporate America won't infect every
does though think about Broadway there
is no original thing on Broadway it's
all movies being adapted for for the UH
and theme park and theme park right yeah
being a duh adopted adapted for the
stage like they're you right there's a
kid somewhere who was a great musical
idea that is never gonna be able to push
it through without well yeah I'm Steve
behind it so what is that about us why
is that we all if you were to ask
anybody they would say oh I want
something original I want something
fresh and Yabu you can identify with it
you've seen the little know what you
expect right right when my pen when I
lived in New York and my parents came to
visit they wanted to see something like
The Little Mermaid because they knew how
the story ended they knew what to look
for and what to wait for it I'm gonna
waste
money right yeah that was oh maybe we're
lazy we're lazy right it i guess it's
why people come to new york city and go
to the Olive Garden in time right we're
lazy you know we're they're lazy ah
apple juice applebees weld is the I will
be still paying to go a lot of Star Wars
movies and I'm gonna drag Wendy and
emboss I'm not dressing up maybe with a
scare oh man who had that hair come on
Fisher Carrie Fisher who played Princess
Leia yeah yeah look at this all right we
did something bonobos calm is the
official outfitter of the Ruben report
use code trr 20 for twenty percent off
your first purchase